If you had the power to come
back from the dead, what would you do?
Your former mentor
has become a revolutionist killer
and you're going to have to help your
worst enemy in order to take him down.
I'm going to break down for mistakes made.
What you should do and how to beat Sato
in Ajin season to come here.
There's a slight error in the script.
We change the name from K in season
one of Ajin to now Nagai in season two.
Or, as Griff would say, Nahguy.
So sorry about that.
These two kids called Nagai
and Nakano will be forced
into taking down
the most dangerous revolutionist in the world.
Sato a.k.a the man in the hat.
These kids have been discovered to be
Ajin, which are types of humans who cannot
die and can summon these black ghosts
to do whatever they want.
These two are running from this guy
called Tosaki, who is an expert Ajin
killer and has just been ordered
by his boss to hunt down Sato.
Sato wants to make Ajin's illegal
in Japan, but since the government has
ignored his wishes, he's
now made a list of 15 powerful people
in Japan who are against his kind
and will begin killing them one by one
until he gets what he wants.
Meanwhile, these Ajin kids
continue to be on the run with no clue
of what to do next, when suddenly
the guy finds out on his phone
that the guy they're running away
from, Tosaki, his wife is in a deep coma.
And so the two pay a visit and tell tell
Tosaki exactly where they're going,
forcing them to meet up with him
face to face to make a deal.
The guy tells a trigger happy to Tosaki
that they should team up to take down
the one person who made both their lives
miserable, Sato himself.
And they agree to team up.
OK, we all know the phrase
the enemy of my enemy is my friend.
But dang, has anybody forgotten
what he has put us through,
what our own government has
put us through?
He works for the government
to hunt down Ajin
and then tortured them
in the name of science till we die
and then come back to life again and again
for profit using what they discovered
from our mangled bodies to advance
technology in medicine and warfare.
This guy is about as trustful as the OG
glasses guy is with a cell phone camera.
We can't trust this guy at all,
but the guy is right about the fact
that we are just a couple of a gym kids
with no money, resources, or practical
training really in combating Sato,
which means we need to think
smart and long term.
However, I wouldn't have relied on Tosaki
good faith into believing us
and teaming up with us
because that was a risky move
and he could have easily turned down
our offer and captured us on the spot
in a much more perfect situation.
I would have tried to gain some good
faith with him before approaching OTosaki.
I would have tried to capture
another bad guy
that they're chasing route to show him
that we mean business and are serious
about making a deal with him.
However,
that wouldn't have been realistic.
We literally have no money or resources
in finding Sato or his henchmen,
but the least they could have done
was not to rush into meeting OTosaki
because the guy found out through
his hacking skills information onto Tosaki
and that his wife
has been in a coma for ages, which means
they're using her as bait to lure
Tazaki was perfect, however, that guy
had had no real reason to rush into
calling to Tosaki as soon as he found out
about his wife's whereabouts.
In setting up a meeting
where tensions are high it's important
to establish a point of contact
that the initiator is familiar with.
The guy proposing the terms should always
try to set the meeting on a familiar home
turf, however, and a guy just rushed into
it, setting up a meeting with TaTosaki
where his wife was, which he no doubt
has been to many times before,
and he's more familiar with the layout
then the guy was the least.
This stupid kid could have done
was to check out the hospital
first, get familiar
with the layout and its escape entrances,
the vent systems and so on,
even if all of this took a while.
Because remember,
we're all alone and OTosaki isn't going
after our family anymore to find us.
We can take our sweet time
to make sure we set things up right.
The guy in Nakano joined with Tazaki
and his a gen hunter task force,
and they watched Sato declare on the news
that he's already begun
killing the people on his list,
which means
they don't have much time to waste.
So Tosaki then begins training them
and sees that the guy is better suited
to being the brains of the operation.
And Tanaka know the muscle.
They meet with this famous Ajin doctor
who Tazaki and his men
kidnaped earlier
and he asks to see the guys Black Ghost.
The guy tells the doctor that his ghost
doesn't follow orders, does the opposite
of whatever he says, and goes on autopilot
after a while doing his own thing.
If the guy doesn't keep him under control,
the engine doctor then suspects that
because his ghost is so dense
and doesn't listen to his orders
that this is related to the mind
and ego of the owner of the Black Ghost.
Meaning that
if the guy wants to fix his broken
black ghost, he needs to fix himself first
because this kid has got some serious
anger issues against everybody
and it's seriously messing with his powers
elsewhere.
Sato gets ready to kill his next target
and asks his crew to put them
in this full makeup outfit because what
he's about to do will shock the world.
He arrives at this airport, sneaks through
security and gets on the plane.
He sits down, seeing nearby
what he's come for his next target.
The plane takes off, not knowing.
Everyone on this plane is already dead.
Now, high in the sky,
Sato gets up and heads to business class.
He kills this guy and these other
two bodyguards terrifying the shit
out of this lady as his black ghost kills
the next victim on his kill list.
He then detonates the bomb
that he brought with him on the plane,
causing the whole thing to come crashing
down, forcing every innocent human
being on board with him to die.
OK, this proves my earlier point.
We don't have time to mess around.
Yes, training to use their black
ghost is important,
but the training regiment that OTosaki has
for these kids is actually very smart
because despite having powers working out
in general, can't provide the user
with many benefits
that will spill over into everyday life,
from reducing stress levels
to improving sharper
memory and thinking, and also
improving your overall cognitive function.
And after what the Ajin doctor
said, the performance of it against Black
Ghost is highly based on the mental
and emotional state of the Ajin himself.
The guy is a smart kid, but he's only
as good as his ability to control himself
in combat, and a large chunk of this
will come down to his mental state.
In fact, Ozaki should have taken this one
step further and included mental drills
commonly used on soldiers
in order to help them
prepare for the trauma of combat
that they will face, such as working
on controlling
aggressive thoughts, relaxation
and cut down on destructive emotions
that can plague the user's
mind, basically getting comfortable
at being uncomfortable.
The guy knows that he has problems
controlling his black ghost
because he himself is not fully stable,
at least stable enough to be able
to control his black ghost effectively.
So rather than relying on the guy
to simply work on himself till Tosaki
should have someone help work
on the guy's mental insides as well,
because working on the fundamental
characteristics of stress, regulation
and mental stability
is just as important as the physical,
and they need all the help
that they can get back at the base.
The guy walks into this room and sees
his coworkers aim their guns at him,
and he lets out his Ajin scream,
which instantly knocks them out.
But Tanaka now comes out pissed as hell
and tells him that they were just
teaching him how to shoot.
The guy tells them
that they can't trust anybody anywhere.
Nakano thinks the guy is acting crazy
and they are.
Then told by the group that Sato has just
killed the next person on his kill list.
This pisses Nagai off
and he runs into the forest
to figure out his black
ghost in the woods.
His black ghost starts trying to kill him
and doesn't listen to anything
the guy says,
freaking him the hell out as his black
ghost goes absolutely nuts on a tree.
The guys to battle hardened for his own
good and his angry emotions are messing
everything up.
Later, Tanaka gets everyone together
and tells them that based on his research,
Sato will most likely kill this guy next
the Labor minister
who has gone into hiding,
which means that they have time to prepare
for Sato's attack.
But Sato manages
to find out the minister's location
and he sends his finest Ajin death hunter
to go after the minister, causing
more horrors and more deaths to rack up
as he kills the minister and everyone else
trying to protect him with brutal ease.
Tazaki later gets word about this
and realizes that Sato is far more deadly
than they thought and tells the team
to speed up their training.
And he tells Nagai to hurry up
and fix himself and his black ghost
because it's still doesn't
listen to anything.
Then a guy tells it.
More days passed by
and they get word that Sato has killed
another person on his kill list.
Now Kono begins freaking out, saying out
loud what everybody is thinking.
They don't have much time left
before Sato kills everyone on his list.
And more trouble comes their way
because the Department of Defense asks
Kozaki to come in for a chat.
They're investigating the death
of this famous Ajin doctor,
the same one that OTosaki kidnaped
and faked his death to cover their tracks
because the only way to stop Sato
will be with the help of this Ajin doctor.
Elsewhere in this prison sits bland guy,
the guy's ex-best friend,
and who helped him?
The guy escaped
when he first discovered his Ajinda.
Powers
he willingly went to prison for that guy.
This guy is best friend goals
and has a heart of gold.
I'm not even kidding.
And he helps this serious face
dude with some prison thugs which causes
serious face do to save his life.
And we discover that blond hair guy
has now become best friends in prison
with a flying Ajin.
Later on back at the base,
the group trains for the fight to come
and OTosaki keeps tabs on one of
the most important people on the list,
this minister and his whereabouts.
They find out that this minister
will hold a meeting with the vice minister
in a few days.
To discuss
new government plans against Sato.
The group prepares to catch Sato during
that meeting and come up with an idea
to find out the location of the meeting
by stealing the minister's schedule.
However, this man and woman
sent by the Department of Defense don't
give a damn about their plans and asked
Ho Tosaki to meet with them.
They think that the famous Ajin
doctor isn't actually dead and believe
that Ozaki has something to do with it.
Tazaki denies everything and walks out
and the later sends in black hair girl
to steal the minister's schedule
by using some crafty admin tricks
and she later takes a peek
at a thumb drive while waiting to.
Tosaki gets kidnaped
by the same men and woman from earlier,
burying a needle into his neck
and forcing him to pass out black hair
girl shows up late to the party,
releasing her black ghost to fight them
but is shocked to see a different black
ghost from another Ajin from this girl.
OK, this is why black hair
girl should not have snuck a peek at that.
I'm dry.
The Department of Defense
is breathing down
our necks about the ajin doctor,
that whole psyche kidnaped
so we can't afford any mistakes.
This Ajin doctor is an American
biophysicist was world
renowned about his scientific
outlook on Ajin's and he knows how black
ghosts are formed and even the science
behind their existence.
Both the American and Japanese governments
are aware of the existence of Ajin's
and have a research agreement sharing info
about Ajin's between the two nations.
Which means that this guy is probably
the most important guy around here
when it comes to Ajin's.
And based on the research agreement
between Japan and the U.S.
and the fact that the Ajin doctor
has dual citizenship with the US too,
Tosaki should have figured out way earlier
that the country of freedom
and bald eagles would have come
knocking on his door eventually,
and because of this
he should have worked a better had tracing
every single speck of evidence that day.
He kidnaped the Ajin doctor
because up until now, till
Tosaki has had ample head start on this,
which he chose not to take advantage of.
Also, the assignment was to steal
the minister's schedule.
It was not to open the thumb drive
right within the compound itself.
There
surely would have been cameras around,
which means that black or girl just risked
the entire operation by being way too
curious and taking a peek at a thumb drive
before she got back to the car.
And if she hadn't done this,
she could have had a better chance
at getting to Tazaki
before he got injected.
Curiosity killed the cat, and in this case
it pretty much killed black hair.
Girl's only shot of saving Tazaki
thanks to her eagerness.
Because let's face it,
if someone is showing up
and accusing you of shit
related to Ajin's, it's safe to say
that they would have implemented
security measures
like bringing along their very own Ajin
for situations like this one.
These two made a fatal error
and it's going to cost them
both of the again
girls look at each other in shock
as they both reveal
their horrifying powers to each other.
They battle it out.
But this blond lady is way
better than black hair girl kicking
your ass and badly wounded before black
hair girl runs away at the last moment
and passes out and team blondie escapes
with toast Tosaki in their car.
Later at an unknown location, they begin
their horrifying plans to interrogate
Tazaki demanding to know where the famous
Ajin doctor is being kept.
But Ozaki has some serious Moomin rider
sized balls and doesn't
tell them shit, forcing blond haired girl
to inject her psyche with a famous toxin.
And this toxin is made
especially for Ajin.
It works by paralyzing
the diaphragm, making the person
feel like they're slowly suffocating.
She steps tazaki as he quickly begins
choking on his own bravery
and sits there helplessly.
OK, this is terrifying
and makes me think that Team Blondie here
is way more sadistic than their homeland
or reappearance makes it seem,
which is really saying something now.
It seems as though this toxin
that blond lady
has is some type of designer drug
since the drug names
that she mentioned doesn't
seem to actually exist at least on paper.
But like any such a designer drug,
this one seems to mimic
the effects of such toxins that disrupt
the parasympathetic nervous system or
the system that regulates bodily function.
Automatically.
To Serkis, breathing was altered
to make him feel like he was suffocating,
to make him feel like he was dying.
This likely means that this drug
interfered with his heart's processes
by inhibiting his sympathetic nervous
system, blocking neuromuscular
transmissions, and forcing his diaphragm
muscle to stop working properly.
The likely drug, similar
to the effects that TaTosaki was injected
with, could have been through the use
of a toxin known as Q Rare, a toxin
that can be found in a class of plants
and is a poison used by Amazon tribes
centuries prior.
This drug is a neurotoxin
that acts as a neuromuscular blocking
Ajint capable of blocking messages
sent by the body's central nervous system
to control the movement of muscle.
It was used for medicinal purposes
in the mid-19th century
as a muscle relaxant during surgeries
that required anesthesia.
This toxin, when administered in proper
dosages, can cause death
by suffocation
due to the paralysis of the diaphragm.
Very similar
right to how Tazaki was affected just now.
The dosage amount to use Q rare
within a safe
range is so slim that doctors don't
even use this crap anymore.
That's how dangerous this stuff is.
However, the effects from Kira
can be reversed with no consequence
if the dosages are small enough.
However, since Team
Blondy is using this drug willy
nilly with no other drugs to cure
Tanaka of this toxin, this makes me think
that they mixed this neurotoxin
with something else
to offset the certainty of death
from this poison.
Since they did mention
that this drug would do not kill Tosca,
only that it would make him feel like
he is dying very slowly.
Back in the parking lot, black haired girl
finally wakes up and runs back to town.
The guy in the rest of them.
What just happened?
She tries to convince them
to stop their plan
to save the minister
in order to save Trotsky first.
And with a little rough convincing,
she gets the guy and the rest of the team
to get on her side to go save to Tosaki.
The Ajin doctor also tells them that
he thinks he knows where they're holding
to Tosaki
at a safe house that they've used before,
and the gang suits up to go save him.
Meanwhile, OTosaki continues
to get brutally tortured as the guy
and his team bust into the same warehouse
and use their again powers and tactics
to defeat all of Team Blondie's minions,
forcing these blond bastards to escape.
And the guy quickly sends his Ajin
to chase after them and puts a tracker
on their car, causing a terrifying car
chase through the city streets.
And the guy and crew try to catch them
before they head to the one place in Japan
where they'll be safe from them.
And the Japanese government,
the United States embassy flying down
narrow city streets.
The guy and crew chased him.
Blondie down black hair
girl takes a back road and surprises
the two and crashes into them
head on the to escape.
A black haired
girl catches up but still recovering,
doesn't have enough strength to summon her
black ghost.
She tries to stop them herself,
but blond girl takes her out with her
black ghost and badly
injures her a get suddenly black
her girl gets so mad that somehow
she unleashes her black ghost, destroying
blond girls and black hair.
Girl shoots blond guy with a sleeping dart
after talking to each other blond
girl decides to betray her master,
shooting him while he's unconscious
and walks away black.
Her girl into Tosaki are quickly
then rescued by the guy in crew.
But psyche freaks out because he realizes
that if they're all here with him,
that that means that the minister is
by himself.
He's all alone.
So Tosaki quickly
calls the minister assistant,
but he tells them that they're too late,
that Sato has already killed the minister,
and that Sato left him alive
to tell the tale.
The group then heads back to their safe
house, sad as hell until Tosaki gives up.
But suddenly
the guy comes up with an important update.
Sato has just uploaded
another terrifying announcement online.
Sato, through the camera
lens, tells the world that he's killed
almost everyone on his kill list.
Except one,
and that he will kill his final target.
This CEO, exactly at this
time, three days from now,
at this meeting, the guy and crew
freak out and so does Sato.
Some minions confused as hell
if they ask Sato why he just revealed
to the world that they are plants.
But Sato tells them to relax,
that it makes the game more fun
because what Sato has planned
will shock everyone on the news.
The President of Japan announces
that due to Sato,
the government has just officially
sanctioned a new team to protect the CEO
and that meeting
this new team is called the
Anti Against Special Forces, handpicked
and specially trained to fight
only against using the latest weapon
technology made by the same company
that this CEO runs. Musashi Industries.
The gang knows that these guys don't have
what it takes to take on Sato,
and so they also prepare
for one last fight against Sato.
The government is using an anti against
special forces unit to capture Sato.
Yeah, it sounds good on paper, but
we all know what happens in season one.
Sato has taken out a special forces team
before.
I get it they're scared
and on the brink of losing their shit.
But really better
weapons is what is going to stop Sato.
This guy avoided an entire government
hell bent on getting him there,
so underestimate their opponents.
They think they now have him beat
with this special forces unit.
Sato knows they're underestimating him,
which is why he basically gave us
and the government
a freebie by revealing his cards
and telling us exactly
when he'll attack next and where.
While on the surface this looks simple,
but if we take a look past Sato,
we can instantly figure out
that this guy is straight up playing us.
Because the only reason
you would ever reveal
your cards is if you're holding
something else up your sleeve.
And it's clear that,
come on, back in the past,
like I said, he's already done
this before.
He's already taken out a Special Forces
unit, and he also snuck onto a plane
and brought a bomb while being the most
wanted person in all of Japan.
And dare I say, the world.
There's
no way he would tell us all of this
unless he had something
to compensate the fact that we know when
and where he's going to attack.
What the government should do is
take a look at what has happened before.
He has used a bomb in the past
and bombs can be made in all shapes
and sizes
and can be used to take down buildings
in a matter of minutes.
And also, if we take a look at the mind of
Sato, he's a jokester, he's a trickster.
He enjoys chaos and enjoys
doing it in the most grandiose
way possible, which means for him
it must be some sort of spectacle.
And what could be more devastating
than a bomb taking out an entire building?
The Anti Against Special Forces Unit
terrifies Sato's crew,
but Sato tells them to relax.
He has a plan more sinister than ever.
Back at the base,
the guide to OTosaki go over their plan
that will take place
during the CEO meeting in a few days,
where Sato will shortly attack to
OTosaki
says that they are only to attack Sato
if the antigen special forces fail
to capture him then and there, because now
that these Special Forces
guys are in the game
so Serkis people can't get in their way.
Tazaki thing goes back to his headquarters
and convinces his boss to let his team
help out because no one knows
what Sato is truly capable of.
A few days later,
the day of the meeting arrives
until Serkis team goes into the building,
sneaking the guy in Nakano
in the whole of Japan prepares for Sato.
Just then a truck suddenly pulls up
and the cops surrounded.
They open the back of the truck
and see a massive device
attached to a laptop in the distance.
Sato, through the camera
on the laptop, stares at the cops
surrounding the truck and presses
a button.
Suddenly a massive explosion
erupts, destroying everything in everyone
nearby and the power everywhere
suddenly goes out.
The general tells everybody
that they've just been hit with an EMP
bomb capable of shutting down
all electronics nearby.
Suddenly drones come flying in
and dove down into the crowd of cops
exploding on impact
and Sato repels down and into the building
and the fight begins.
It's a chaotic bloodbath.
Sato's right hand man this long haired guy
then calls his black ghost to take these
soldiers out, brutally tearing them apart.
But then he gets shot and losing all hope
until Sato finally comes out from hiding
and he's pissed he then goes hand to hand
with these two guys and beats them
with ease,
moving with more precision and skill
than anyone this group has ever seen,
and they quickly get overwhelmed
and defeated.
Sato's team that heads up the stairs
and they get fired upon again.
But this time it's the guys crew
and the two teams carry on the firefight.
Sato slips behind them and enters
the conference room.
But finds the guy holding the CEO hostage.
The guy
then blames Sato for ruining his life
and tells him to drop his weapon or else.
And Sato agrees.
Then suddenly these two shoot at Sato
with tranquilizers,
but they get blocked by his black ghost.
Sato smiles wide, but then gets shot
by a third tranquilizer.
It's the guy's black ghost from above.
Sato then plops down to the floor
and the gang celebrates
because a black ghost is only deadly
if the engine is awake to control it.
But they don't realize what hell
they've just cost because suddenly
black hair girl gets shot and they realize
that Sato's Black Ghost is still moving
while Sato is unconscious.
The guy then trembles in fear
as he gets knocked down by Sato's ghost
and it kills Sato
and brings him back to life.
Good as new.
The guy then looks on in sheer terror
as Sato bust out the front door
and begins shooting and the guys team
that is still fighting against Sato's crew
and the guy badly injured can do nothing
but watch as Sato takes out his teammates
one by one and Sato returns
and prepares to cutting the guy's head off
just like he promised.
Way back
when just then a military helicopter shows
up, forcing Sato and his team to back off
and make a getaway.
Well, that went well.
Not the guy from the get
go should have thought that
if he was capable of controlling his black
ghost while unconscious, then probably
he wasn't the only Ajin who could do this.
Out of all legends, Sato,
with his experience,
could probably have been capable
of doing the same thing.
And also the Ajin doctor
is partially to be blamed for this because
someone as capable as Sato should have had
some form of record on file.
We know that Sato was in the military
before,
which means that he had to have
had some sort of record on file.
They put way too much faith
in their assumption that Sato wasn't
capable of what the guy is
because as we can clearly see, he was.
The guy gets captured by the military
and Sato and his team escape
and Sato even kills the CEO
shocking his whole team.
But Sato then says that this CEO wouldn't
have granted their kind any civil rights
and that they'll have to put on a big show
in order to get what they want.
And Sato's team opens up this weaponized
vault in preparation for what's to come.
But these guys have no idea
just how truly insane Sato really is.
Back on the ground
till Serkis team catches a breather
and goes all self defeated for a second
until Tazaki puts his boss
this glasses guy to sleep and freezing
the guy in Nakano and everyone escapes
back at the base to Tosaki blames
all of this crap on the guy
until Tosaki tells the whole team
to give up.
The guy goes and cries in his room
for a little bit as Sato goes on the news
and reveals that his kill list is over
and that within ten days
he'll begin the final wave
and that he plans to seriously negotiate
with the government this time.
The next day, Sato's team reaches
this military compound in trucks,
and he shoots these two guys
as more and more trucks enter.
And that's when the chaos begins.
A wave of these undead again
warriors began sweeping this base
and kill
every single last soldier to be seen,
and they quickly overtake the base's
armory.
And Sato then makes another
live broadcast, saying that
one week from today, all non-Indians
in Japan must evacuate this country.
And he's going to turn this place
into purely an ajin territory.
And if they don't, he'll use these weapons
to kill everyone.
So Tosaki and his team
see Sato's madness live and agree
to try and take him out one last time.
Back at the president of Japan's office,
they go over the situation
and discuss what Sato has
and what he's truly capable of.
Holck This is nuts
and this proves that Sato is certifiable.
Crazy.
These missiles that Sato is threatening
to destroy Japan with contain nerve
Ajints, also known as nerve gas,
which is a class of organic chemical
that disrupts the mechanisms by
which nerves transfer messages to organs.
Hence the name a nerve gas.
Because death by one of these can occur
within minutes.
Added works by ensuring death
by respiratory arrest through the effect
it has on the diaphragm, paralyzing it
and also affecting the area
of the brain stem that controls
breathing known as the respiratory center.
This weapon is basically a neurotoxin
on roids and even a low dose of it
from one of these bad boys can ensure
that his victims experience a variety
of neurological and mental disorders
from loss of memory, mental confusion
and cognitive problems.
Sato killed almost every single person
on his kill list.
He knowingly killed every person
that was capable of having the laws
change in order to granted their ajin
kind rights.
He murdered that minister from earlier.
That guy could have helped Sato enact laws
they could have helped against.
The fact that he killed him
means he had no intention
of making an agreement
with the government.
There was way less extreme measures
that he could have taken
in order to get what he wanted.
I have two options for the government.
One Give to OTosaki
actually full governmental support
and resources that will make their efforts
in getting to Sato much easier or option
to vaporize the compound.
Right now.
Let's see how well Ajin
survive a land to air missile.
Go ahead.
Let the chemical weapons get destroyed.
Because if the missile blast doesn't
incinerate the entire area
and the chemicals that nerve gas paralyzes
the diaphragm right.
Are breathing muscle, then wouldn't
that mean that most Ajints wouldn't
be able to wake back up and even if they
did, they would suffocate and pass out
and that's if they survived the blast,
which I highly doubt.
I believe the combined destruction
of military grade weapons
and buildings would kill everybody
and anybody in the area.
Back at the Armory, Sato, Lexi's lips
and everything going on
and the government contacts
them and tells Sato
that they're willing to work with them
and that they're willing to make
some Japanese islands nearby
an official Ajinda nation.
And this gets all the other Ajints
excited as hell.
But then Sato spits in their face
and does the craziest thing ever.
He launches the nerve gas missiles,
launching it right near the president's
office, killing two people and horrifying
everyone else, even the Ajin.
And he tells everyone that they now
have three days to evacuate Japan or else.
Sato's crew finally thinks he's too crazy,
but Sato threatens
to cut off their heads
if they don't follow his orders
and they realize that Sato
doesn't give a damn about their future.
All he cares about
is the thrill of battle.
And so his crew decides
to sneak away through the sewers and head
towards the one person
they know who could help them.
The guy at the president's office,
they decide to release poison gas through
underground tunnels
near the armory and around that area,
killing everyone innocent and guilty.
Nearby, Sato's crew calls
the guy and asks to meet.
They tell him that they want to join
the team
and are willing to help the guy
take Sato down.
And in return they ask for their freedom.
Both sides agree to work together
and they even total Tosaki where Sato is
hiding and everyone heads to task his base
and he goes over the battle plan.
They plan to capture
Sato before the military releases
the poison gas, but the guy has an idea.
This is all a game to Sato,
which means that Sato has a weakness
they can use later on.
Sato and long haired dude sit and wait
and they then get an alert
that someone is coming and Sato gets ready
for the incoming military.
But just now Guy shows up, surprising Sato
and pissing him off because no one gets
between him and his games.
The guy calls out his black ghost
but gets defeated quickly by Sato
and the team quickly runs away with a guy
calling on multiple black
ghosts to slow down Sato
as they lead him right here.
Sato aims his sights on the group
when all of a sudden an explosion erupts
and the guy tells them that they plan
to bury him alive right here and now.
But Sato is one step ahead of them
and takes out his own phone
and detonates his own bomb nearby, burying
everyone instead.
OK, look,
these guys were at the end of their rope
and they almost had Sato dead to rights.
The guy here is the smartest of the lot.
Sure, but boy did he act dumb here.
This is the one time where they could have
outsmarted Sato and allowed him
no backup plan because at this point
we know Sato always has a backup plan.
We have to make sure Sato doesn't
think he needs to trigger his backup plan
until it's too late. At the last moment.
The guy chose to go
the route of every James Bond villain ever
and comment on how he was going to get
to Sato rather than just saying nothing
and blowing the whole place up to hell.
We could have even had not going to go
fight him head on and continuously
keep Sato busy
and not realize what we are about to do.
Because think about this.
This orange hair
bozo has a heart full of gold
and is the sweetest of the bunch.
Yes, but he's also the strongest of us
here.
And the fit tests
that OTosaki put us through showed that
he is faster, stronger than the guy is.
The guy should have risked permanently
killing not Kono.
If that meant he could have distracted
Sato up until the last moment
the gang wakes up scattered and injured,
trapped underground,
and Sato wants to play one last game
with them all like her girl is terrified
as her black ghost tries to slow down
Sato, but nothing can stop him.
He kills this guy and closes in on her
like her girl done running,
decides to face Sato herself
but gets shot by Sato with ease.
He even prepares to kill this girl,
but the guy's black ghost stops him.
No one can do anything and Sato
beats them all
cutting off, knocking his hands
and beating the shit
out of the guy and long haired guy
then shows up to help Sato.
He tries to kill black hair girl
just as not Kono's Black Ghost stops him
distracting him just long enough
until black hair girl shoots him
with a sleeping dart,
making him pass out nearby
and the guy now out of energy backs up
as Sato prepares to cut off his head,
staring death in the face suddenly causes
the guy to release a flood of black
ghosts everywhere,
killing Sato and chopping off his head,
defeating him.
The government arrives to capture Sato
with Tosaki showing up with the agreement
to let these again.
Kids remain under his control and
the group goes back to their normal lives.
Little do they realize Sato isn't done
and he escapes with long haired dude
these two ain't done with terrifying Japan
and they prepare
for their second playthrough.
But what do you guys think about Ajin
Season two?
Let us know what you like
and what you didn't like.
Don't forget to leave a thumbs up.
And also don't forget to check
out our How to Bait videos.